let's see what we got here this is uh
quite entertaining i mean why though
what is going on here he tried to make
that sit up a little hard look look
risk over reward don't do it people risk
is too big don't do it now if you're
gonna do that can't you take a little
plate and just you know what he's trying
to do this little thing this little
movement like even then like there's so
much better ways to do what you're
trying to achieve like did you see this
stuff though like they've cut videos you
do see it now i like there's one that
i've seen now i guess it's like a trend
going on where you got these guys
um you know usually people they'll do
pull-ups and they'll put like a
kettlebell or some weight to you know
get stronger in their pull-ups now
they're putting a whole entire bench
like a benching bench strapped to the
the weight belt and they're literally
doing pull-ups with a freaking bench
hanging from their legs i think that we
have one we might have that the guys to
take the ellipticals up with them or the
bikes up with them stop not going to see
that if you have a bike i gotta see that
stop it i gotta see that okay let's do
the second one i don't remember what i
pulled here so i don't know if you have
this one is tough to see because it's
like all different stuff it's a
compilation look she's going all the way
up off the shoes this guy i've seen this
guy
playing around i know some type of spit
this one i don't know what he's doing
standing on one leg up in the middle of
the air this guy's still going in the
back frogger this is terrible she's
afraid to do the jump clearly that's too
high for her takes it oh oh oh and then
oh and then over the neck
that was more she just needed a nose she
needed to bring that box bring that box
down to like half the half the height
when i met my husband he was doing box
jumps like that i'm not kidding
it was like this high and i was like
this guy's got springs in his feet and i
was like how's he doing that that was
like the first intrigue i had toward him
i was like what is going on over there i
definitely wasn't able to jump that high
i'll tell you that
all right we got one more from
hard aesthetics i think it's called when
the personal trainer leaves you alone
for 10 minutes look oh my gosh
what is that
what is that
listen you got it he's trying to get
creative he's and it's it is funny
though because if even if you work with
a trainer
i don't know what happens man something
clicks off in the brain and i have it
too the second they leave i'm like
i can just turn i can turn around on
this machine and do it the opposite way
i'm like all of a sudden i can do it
from midair like i got all these ideas
oh look i can do it with my feet on a
ball and i'm suspended in midair oh look
i can hold the trx like this i i am that
person like my shoulder dislocation was
my fault because i was in a ridiculous
position
but what happens to us when the trainers
leave the room it's like we think we've
learned enough
to just get creative and sometimes i
guess the confidence maybe a little too
much maybe maybe
i got one story yeah to share because
you guys are gonna laugh yeah um so you
guys are familiar with the power plate
yeah yeah yeah okay so the power plate
so i remember i just started for people
who aren't can you explain what that is
like a vibrating machine and you you
know you basically stand on it you can
do certain exercises you can use it for
ulcer recovery or to change you know
like basically the base of support so it
can challenge you to be able to get
stronger you like stand on stability
hold it like vibrating and it vibrates
um there's different levels i think it
goes up to 10 depending on the model so
i just started at equinox i think it was
there like three four months um
and i and i remember i was there on the
floor doing my floor shifts i got some
of my buddy my colleagues there's like
three or four of them and they're
laughing in a corner and i'm like yo
what are you guys laughing at it's like
3 4 3 45 4 p.m
and um they're like bro just come over
here like all right all right so i go
over there
and i'm like all right what's going on
what are we looking at they're like just
look at the power play i'm like okay
i'll just look at the power play five
minutes pass by i'm like what's going on
and they're like bro just chill just
chill wait until you see the person
they're gonna come out of the bathroom
whatever just watch the power play i'm
like okay so we see this lady come out
and i'm like we're looking at her and
he's like yeah keep looking so lady
comes out and she goes to the corner
grabs like four or five yoga blocks and
she starts stacking it on the power play
stacks it can't end well
she puts like two like this two like
this and then she puts one pointing up
then she grabs all the towels from
equinox right there in the corner starts
putting towels all over the yogurt i'm
like like what is this lady doing and
they're like just keep watching
and um
she sits and then straddles it and then
she rips the power plate to like level
10 and she's holding on the bars
and she's with her eyes rolling back and
i'm like is this lady doing what i think
she's doing
and i was like
this lady is using the power plate
as a vibrator no stop
and she was literally going to town just
there with her legs like this and eyes
rolling back and she was just like this
the whole time like was this like young
or an older woman older woman like
closer to 50. and i was just like what
is going on here and we're just like and
i was like does this happen like she
comes every like tuesday and thursday
she comes right before rush hour she
does her little 10 minute routine and
then she goes to the cardio section and
i'm like well she's making the best use
of her membership using the power play
as whatever is power plate whatever it's
called as a vibration no shame if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]